[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
41 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I'm Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hey, Francesc.
How are you doing today?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Doing great
knowing that I beat you
yesterday at ping pong.
MARK MANDEL: And I beat
you twice, so there you go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, OK, whatever.
Let's forget about that.
So I'm very happy today, because
we're going to be talking with
Tim Kelton from Descartes
Labs, or "Des-car-tez" Labs,
depending on how good
your French is or not.
And he's going to be
telling us about how
to use Google Cloud to do maps.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, he is.
It's a really interesting
story around, particularly,
preemptible VMs, actually.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, preemptible VMs,
and really, really,
really big data sets.
MARK MANDEL: Really
big data sets.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah,
very excited about that.
I really enjoyed talking to him,
so I hope that you will also
enjoy the interview.
And then, at the end, we will
have a question of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we're going
to talk a little bit about what
you can get for free.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
which is always good.
MARK MANDEL: Free stuff is good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So concretely, what
are the products
or features or APIs
that you can use for
free up to a given point?
So what products have free
tiers in Google Cloud Platform?
We're going to be discussing
them a little bit-- not giving
all of them, because there's too
many products-- but to give you
an idea what you can
do for free, basically.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
But before that, we
have the cool thing of the week.
And as usual, it is the
cool things of the week.
MARK MANDEL: I think
we should just rename
the section cool things--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
we should just rename it.
MARK MANDEL: --of the week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, so the
two first ones are actually
related to the podcast.
It's a meta cool
thing of the week.
The first one is
we got transcripts.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
which is really cool.
So now we get automated
transcripts coming through.
There will be at least
15 out, because that's
how many I have right now
on the website available.
But we'll be
gradually increasing
that to increase all of them.
So if you want to see the text
or read the actual podcast,
it's pretty cool.
You can do that.
And the other thing is the
thing you built, as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, so I've
been working on it for a couple
days.
And it involves FFmpeg
and Docker and Go
and lots of things.
But now we will be releasing
every single episode
from the Google Cloud
Platform Podcast to YouTube.
So that's going
to be pretty cool.
I already posted three of them,
but they are still not public.
But by the time this
episode comes out,
probably everything will be out.
So go check it out.
We'll have a link to the
playlist from the show notes.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I think
this is actually kind of cool,
because if you subscribe
to YouTube videos,
you can do that anyway, so
that gives you another avenue
to subscribe to the podcast.
But if you're a YouTube
Red or Google Play Music
person who owns a
subscription to that
means you can download
them for offline use, too.
So you can actually
listen to it much like you
would a regular podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
Yeah, I didn't think about that.
That is cool.
And yeah, I'm actually
very excited also
about the transcripts, because
I got an email a long time
ago at the beginning of
the podcast from someone
saying that they had problems
understanding English,
and they would rather have
the written version of it.
So cool, perfect,
we have it now.
MARK MANDEL:
Absolutely, perfect.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And then we
have a non-meta cool thing
of the week, an actual cool
thing of the week, which
is gRPC hit the version 1.0.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
this is really cool.
I'm a huge, huge fan of gRPC,
which is a remote procedure
call framework that came out of
Google that's open source, that
has been kind of under
development for a while,
but has now hit 1.0, which means
there's a lot more-- they've
improved the performance of it.
Installing all the tools
is now a lot easier.
My favorite thing, actually, is
they've released a performance
dashboard that's available.
You can go look there and see,
like, what sort of throughput
you can expect to get with
different language comparisons,
because gRPC supports about
10 different languages.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, that is nice.
Yeah, I also saw that there's
a bunch of people using it
from open source
projects like [INAUDIBLE]
or containerd and CockroachDB,
but also companies.
So I think that the biggest
one that is using it
is Netflix and Google.
We actually have APIs that
only work with gRPC already,
like Bigtable.
And then there's other APIs that
have both REST and gRPC APIs.
So yeah, check it out.
We'll have links to the
announcement from the show
notes.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Cool, well that sounds
all really awesome.
Why don't we go talk to Tim?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
let's go to that.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good.
It's my distinct
pleasure to announce
that we are joined
today by a gentleman
by the name of Tim Kelton,
from Descartes Labs.
How are you doing today, Tim?
TIM KELTON: I'm
doing really good.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Thank you so much
for joining us today.
Pretty excited to
be talking to you.
I think the stuff you
do and the company
you work for do some
really interesting stuff.
But tell us a little about
you, and who you are,
and what you do, and
all that kind of stuff.
TIM KELTON: Sure.
I'm an engineer and part
of the founding team
here at Descartes.
And my main focus is Cloud
architecture, and then building
and scaling what we call
our Cloud supercomputer,
which is basically a
forecasting platform.
And so I end up using a range
of Google Cloud Platform tools
to accomplish this goal.
And that's mainly to
see how the Earth is
changing every single day.
And before Descartes, I was
a research and development
engineer for 15 years at Los
Alamos National Laboratory.
And there, I worked on a
wide range of projects,
but it was focused around deep--
the most recent project that
lasted about six years was
focused around deep learning
and applying deep learning
to real world problem areas,
like satellite imagery.
And then a portion
of that team left
Los Alamos to start Descartes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So you mentioned
that Descartes Lab,
it allows you to see
how the Earth changes.
What does that mean?
TIM KELTON: Yeah,
so we're building
a living atlas of the world.
And how we're doing that is
we're applying machine learning
with massive scale data sets,
such as satellite imagery,
also data sets like global
weather, pricing, [INAUDIBLE]
truth, even customer data.
And then we feed that into
our forecasting platform.
And then we can build our
machine learning models
and constantly try and
improve those models.
And this allows
us to not just see
what's happened
historically, but also it
lets us forecast
into the future.
Kind of interestingly
enough, we mainly
are focused on areas that humans
just could never scale to do,
things like global-scale
food production.
You just couldn't
get enough people
on the ground counting
how productive a field is
all over the world.
It just isn't scalable.
So we're using satellite
data in that way.
And it's really exciting.
We're only 20 months old,
so it's a really early stage
company.
But we're moving really quickly.
MARK MANDEL: So exactly how
much data are you talking about?
You're talking about satellite
imagery and forecast weather.
I mean, how big are
these data sets?
TIM KELTON: So the
data sets vary.
Right now we currently
have compressed
around three and a
half petabytes of data
that we're storing in a
Google Cloud Platform.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, only a couple
of petabytes, it's fine.
TIM KELTON: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: And that
process is, like,
that's over a number of years?
Is that, like, recently?
Like, what's that sort
of time series, as well?
TIM KELTON: Yeah, that's
an interesting area.
As most people that do machine
learning or use tools like Cafe
or TensorFlow can tell
you, a really big challenge
with machine learning tools is
having an accurate set of data
to train the models and then
improve the models' accuracy.
And when you're doing things
like looking at the Earth,
having a really large time
window of data helps out a lot.
And often with satellite
data, training sets
can be extremely varied.
And things like weather cycles
are not just repeatable year
after year.
They vary quite a
bit through time.
So the longest continuous
observations of the Earth
came from NASA's
Landsat constellation.
And that was launched in 1973.
And that's actually available,
thanks to the Google Earth
Engine team, on Google Cloud.
And so our first big project
really early on in the company
was we basically saw we
needed a lot of backtest data
to be able to test
models throughout time.
And we basically
processed 43 years
of this NASA Landsat imagery.
So in pixel terms, that's going
to be 2.8 petapixels of data.
In data terms, that's
about a petabyte of data.
And so we did all of that
on Google Compute Engine.
And that was about just
a little under 16 hours.
And that's using 30,000
virtual CPU cores.
And that was all
on preemptible VMs.
So it was quite sizable.
And I should say that as
impressive as Google Compute
Engine scaling up, probably
the most interesting part to us
was GCE's network and how well
the network actually scaled.
We were actually seeing,
for most of that 16 hours,
over 20 gigabytes a second going
into Google Compute Engine,
and then over 8 gigs
in parallel going out
of Google Compute Engine.
And we've worked in
places-- most of us
come from Los Alamos,
or have worked
on other large-scale
supercomputing clusters.
And those types of
numbers are on par
with anything you would see in
a high-performance supercomputer
system today.
So we basically are
using Google to build
the same types of systems that
we were used to working with.
Google recently actually had
a paper about their networking
called-- I think it's maglev.
And so that was
really fascinating.
As an end user, we
saw how it scaled,
and that was really interesting.
But then reading
the paper of how
all those components
were built together
was pretty fascinating.
MARK MANDEL: So you were
processing that entire petabyte
data set during that time?
TIM KELTON: Yeah, we
were running that all
through our processing pipeline.
MARK MANDEL: And how much,
roundabouts, is that cost?
I mean, you talked a little
bit about preemptible VMs
there, but--
TIM KELTON: So preemptibles
dramatically reduce your costs
if your workload doesn't
need to last over 24 hours.
So for this use
case, our whole goal
was to get it done
in under a day,
and they were great for that.
When we ran this in early
2015, the cost for just Compute
was just under $10,000.
But then I recently just looked
at-- there was recent pricing
drops in Compute Engine.
And so those prices now
would be about $3,600.
So that kind of shows the
difference in pricing.
That's not the data storage.
The data storage is a
little more than that.
MARK MANDEL: But to go
through a petabyte, that's
not too shabby.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, that
is pretty amazing, actually.
So you mentioned real quick
about preventable VMs.
MARK MANDEL: Preemptible?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What did I say?
MARK MANDEL: You
said preventable.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Preventable, no.
Preemptible VMs, sorry.
Why did you choose them?
What is the big thing?
I understand that it is more
affordable than the normal VMs.
But what kind of
restrictions and what kind
of design decisions did
you take into account?
TIM KELTON: Yeah, so
preemptibles, at maximum,
will only last you for 24 hours.
And so you need to be processing
some sort of processing task
that's going to obviously
last less than that.
So you're not going to run
a production web server
or database server on that.
But for really large
processing workloads,
such as machine
learning, model training,
having a lot of
pre-processing pipelines,
they're a great
use case for that.
For us, we use
asynchronous task queues
to load data, or the
processing we're going to do,
into the task queue,
and then connect up
all these preemptible
instances via instance groups.
And then you can scale up
and down the instance groups.
And now you can scale up and
down the instance groups inside
of a zone in different regions.
So that's quite useful.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So you were able
to sort of leverage
the power of preemptible VMs
to basically reduce your costs,
more than anything else
TIM KELTON: Yeah,
it's a huge cost
reduction compared
to just running
a regular VM for a few hours.
So we use them quite heavily in
all of our processing pipelines
now as a cost reduction.
But also with machine
learning, a lot of times
you're training and retraining
a model to try and improve
your accuracy.
So we have a lot of really
large-scale bulk workloads.
And we've kind of taken the
road of not going down the path
of using something
like Hadoop or things,
because we have a lot of
C and C++ and Python code.
And so instead, we basically
use Google Cloud Storage
as our large
distributed file system.
And we know that will scale
way beyond our current needs.
And it has really, really
fast network access
from Compute Engine, so we
can connect real quickly.
So it has a lot of benefits
over trying to get C or C++
or Python code to work inside
of something like Hadoop.
MARK MANDEL: But the issue,
obviously-- or maybe not
obviously-- but the issue
with preemptible VMs
is they could shut down.
How do you deal
with that happening?
Is there, like, a retry
mechanism you use?
Or how do you deal with that?
TIM KELTON: Yeah, we
use some pretty basic
open source task queues.
We use a Python
queue called Celery.
And that has a backend
persistent store.
You can configure a
bunch of different ones.
We use Redis.
We're pretty big fans of Redis.
And so we write all the
tasks into the queue.
And then basically,
if they still
are not done within a certain
time, you can retry the tasks
or rerun certain tasks over
again and make sure you've
processed all of your work.
Our workloads are,
in many situations,
they kind of fall into this
embarrassingly parallel
problem.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
you mentioned that you
were using asynchronous tasks.
Can you talk a little
bit more about that?
Are you using Pub/Sub?
Are you using task queues?
What kind of product
are you using?
TIM KELTON: We just use
an open source library.
It's called Celery.
It's a Python library.
And that has
configurable backends.
And on that backend we
use Redis in-memory.
And that's all just running
on a regular-- that's
on a non-preemptible
instance, because we do not
want that to go away.
And then for monitoring, we use
the Redis Stackdriver agent.
And that keeps track of how
many concurrent connections
and how much load for various
threads on the Redis cluster
that's running there.
That's kind of a great
way to see if there's
a sudden spike or change.
When that's kind
of your central hub
that all your work
runs around, you
need that to really
be up and be reliable.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So we talked a bit
about, obviously,
that initial data set.
I'm guessing you have ongoing
data that's coming in now.
As your company's expanded, you
have more and more information
coming in on an ongoing basis.
Would that be right?
TIM KELTON: Correct.
We're processing data probably
right now as we're talking.
We're basically
constantly ingesting
new data in our
processing pipelines,
literally from hundreds
of different satellites,
not just those eight
NASA Landsat satellites.
Right now, we're at about
three and a half petabytes
of compressed data.
And a lot of that's
public satellite imagery
that's open-- NASA, European
Space Agency, various people
like that.
But then we also have
private partners, as well.
And so we're constantly,
as we get new updates
to various geographic
regions, or we're
working on a new problem case
maybe inside of agriculture,
or studying a new crop that's in
a different part of the world,
we'll look at different
sets of imagery
that we might not always
hit every single day.
We have about five
terabytes a day
that just constantly flows in.
And that varies from day to day.
But in the future, we're
expecting this to basically
be over 30 petabytes in
the next year and a half.
And that's kind of a cool thing
in space right now, or in space
and technology.
Most of your listeners probably
watch YouTube videos of SpaceX,
and SpaceX landing rockets on
a floating barge in the middle
of the Pacific Ocean.
It's pretty awesome.
But from a cost
perspective, a big part
of your cost to getting
satellites up into orbit
is actually the rocket launches
and making them reusable.
And then at the
other side of that,
you have smaller and
smaller satellites.
And so they're made with more
and more commodity parts.
They're often called CubeSats.
An example of that would
be a Silicon Valley
startup called Planet.
Or Google has a team
called Terra Bella.
And they have what
they call a smallsat.
So you have that
on the other end.
So we're going to get
more and more sensors
in the next few years
going up into space, seeing
the Earth every single day.
And teams like ours
will be able to look
at how the Earth is
changing every single day,
instead of people manually
downloading an image
and trying to
compare one to one.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So going
back to your stack, what
is the thing that is running
on your preemptible machines?
Are you running
Python directly there?
Are you using containers?
What kind of jobs do you run?
TIM KELTON: We use
both raw code, where
we use startup scripts
in the GCE instances,
and we use containers
on some of the more
involved configurations
that we want
to maintain consistency
and make sure a running,
tested version of
the code is operating
in a way we're expecting.
We'll use startup scripts
with instance groups,
so they could either connect
to Google Container Registry
and pull the container
down, because that's really,
really quick access to
pull that container,
because it's just sitting in
Google Cloud Storage inside
of our project.
Or if we run a startup script,
then you're kind of just
defining scripts
to run and install.
But most of our
workload is Python
or C or C wrapped
in Python, Cython,
for most of our workloads.
And I think Python's a pretty
popular language in the machine
learning world these days.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So I'm actually really curious.
You've probably looked at more
satellite data than, I don't
know, maybe a lot of people.
I'm kind of curious to know what
are the most interesting things
you've managed to find
out about the planet
or society as a whole.
Like, what have you seen in
those imagery that's kind
of been really interesting?
TIM KELTON: Yeah,
that's a tough-- you
see all types of random things.
The funniest-- maybe not funny.
It's very obvious after a while.
You don't realize how cloudy the
Earth actually is in many times
of the day.
Often when you're
trying to find an image,
if there's a big sporting
event or something like that,
you have a cloud
actually blocking.
So we actually have a technique
for being able to process
and fuse together
many different scenes
to remove the clouds over time.
But yeah, I'm trying to
think of something really,
really bizarre I've seen.
One of our co-founders,
he actually
located the spot and the
time when the original
"Star-- the original
"Star Wars" movie,
where it was actually filmed.
He went all the
way back and found
this, because we have
this massive archive,
basically since 1973.
And so he found all the exact
images from that location.
MARK MANDEL: That's pretty cool.
I guess more day to day, I know
you do a lot around food yields
as well, I think.
Is that right?
TIM KELTON: Correct.
Our first main
products are actually
focused a little bit
more in agriculture,
and basically modeling
the global food supply.
We look down on the earth, and
we can see various fields all
across a growing region,
not just a small county,
but we could see a whole
state or whole country,
or even the whole globe.
And we can see that
every single day.
So organizations like the
US Department of Agriculture
will manually send out
surveys to farmers.
And they'll get a small
statistical sampling
of the population and how the
food production is growing.
But we basically are
seeing every field, all
across the globe,
every single day,
and taking a measurement of the
actual health of the fields.
And so that allows us to
not just classify the fields
and what they are, if it's
a corn field or a soybean
field or a wheat
field, but also to be
able to look at how much is
that field going to produce
and what's our estimate.
And that leads us into what we
have as more of a forecasting
product.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That is
actually very interesting.
Do you use any
kind of forecasting
to be able to predict
things like, well, given
the kind of fields we have and
given the weather forecasts
that we have, there's
going to be a lack of food
in some country in a couple
months, something like that?
Is that something
that you've ever used?
TIM KELTON: I don't think
we're going quite that far
down the analysis,
like is there going
to be famine outbreak
in country X or Y.
It's definitely something
that could be possible.
Right now we're looking
at overall yields.
There's obviously a lot of--
how much production of corn
might there be in the United
States in this growing season,
or in South America during
this growing season?
But longer term,
we're hoping to expand
to more and more crops and
more and more geographic
regions, basically.
And we also actually have a
new mobile app that we built.
We actually built
it on Firebase.
We have an iOS and Android app.
And anyone can
actually pull that down
and see our delayed forecast.
It's not in real time,
it's a week behind.
And they can actually use
that to look up that location
and see what we're predicting
to be the yield of corn,
say, for that given county in
Iowa or someplace like that.
And you can even vote.
And you can say,
well, we actually
think you're totally wrong, or
yes, that seems about right.
And you can kind of
provide feedback there.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right, that
was really great.
Before we wrap up here,
is there anything else
you want to mention, maybe
something we've missed
or something you want to
kind of mention or plug?
TIM KELTON: That's
the main things.
Moving forward, we're
really excited about some
of the new changes on
Kubernetes and being
able to actually
run jobs, and then
having auto scaling on jobs.
So we are hoping that more and
more of our daily processing
pipeline will be able
to work that way.
So that's pretty exciting.
And then, we should be
having more and more updates,
obviously, with our mobile
app and our website.
So if you're excited about
corn yields or soybean yields,
you'll be able to
key in on that.
I'm not sure what we're
predicting in the Bay Area.
I'm guessing it's pretty
minimal right now.
But yeah, we'll constantly
have new updates.
And we'll always be
improving our models
and working to try and make
them more and more accurate
and use that large
set of data to improve
the accuracy in our forecasts.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
Well, thank you so much for
taking the time to talk to us
and tell us about so many
cool predictions, really.
That was really,
really interesting.
TIM KELTON: Well thanks, guys.
I enjoyed it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thanks again, Tim,
for such an amazing interview.
I learned a lot about how you
can manage such a huge amount
of data with preemptible VMs.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it
was super, super cool.
And just, like, the
large amount of storage
and the amount of data that
they have moving around
the system at any given point
in time is pretty incredible.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it is pretty amazing.
We'll have links.
Actually, we'll have
images in the show notes,
so you can have an idea of the
kind of maps they generates
if you're curious about it.
But now it's time to go with
the question of the week.
And the question
of the week, I'm
not sure where it comes from.
But I know that I had
it in the last GDG
in San Francisco, which was
about Google Cloud Platform.
One of our coworkers,
Terry, gave a talk.
And at the end,
someone asked, OK,
so what are the things I can
do for free on Google Cloud
Platform?
And the first part
of the question
is, well, when you sign up
for Google Cloud Platform,
you get already $300 that
are valid for two months.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, 60 days.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, 60 days.
So with that, you
can do many things.
Like, $300 is a decent
amount of money.
You can run many instances
for quite a while.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I'd generally
say people will probably
run out of the 60 days before
they run out of the $300,
generally speaking.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Generally speaking,
yeah, unless you
go and you start,
like, a 32 core instance
and stuff like that.
That's likely to be more.
But otherwise, yeah, you
should be fine with that.
But even without signing
up and actually going
through the free
trial, there's also
some products that allow you to
have a free tier that is there
forever, no limit of time.
So you can just be there
and use it for free.
And I actually do
it all the time.
One of them is App Engine, which
is one of my favorite ones.
So the free tier is 28 free
instance hours per day.
MARK MANDEL: So you can
get like one point--
I'm not going to do the math--
slightly more than that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I think
we all know how you--
MARK MANDEL: I don't do
things in my head [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, so slightly more than
a day for a frontend instance
is available to be used.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And the good
thing is that most of the time,
you're actually going to
use way less than that,
because if you don't
have that much traffic,
the instances will shut
down automatically.
So in general, that
is way more than
enough for your personal
projects and stuff like that.
So that is pretty awesome.
And once you have
that, it is like, oh,
so do I have access to
any other free things?
I need to store data.
Well, you can use the
Datastore for free.
And I think it is the
first gigabyte, right?
Yeah, the first gigabyte
of storage is free.
And then you can do up to
50,000 reads, 20,000 writes,
and 20,000 deletes.
And that is per day.
So 50,000 reads per day, it
is a decent amount of traffic.
So you can check it out.
Also, you get some other things,
like mail and your fetch,
and task queues.
There is also different levels
of free tiers for those.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
and it's worth
noting now with Datastore, it's
not just tied to App Engine
anymore.
So if you're using Datastore
outside of App Engine,
you still sit into that
free tier, as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh yeah, you
can totally use the REST API
and get that free tier, also.
What else?
MARK MANDEL: So there
is also BigQuery,
one of our most favorite
big data processing
tools, that gives you the
first terabyte of data
process per month to be free.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Which is
really cool, especially
if you're playing with any
of our public data sets
and you want to have a
go with some of those
to see what's possible.
You can do a fair
bit of processing
without having to worry
about paying for it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
even if you don't
want to use the
public data sets,
you can also upload yours.
You don't pay for
uploading data.
You pay for how much data
you're actually storing.
But it's only $0.02
per gigabyte per month.
So you can get started quite
easily for not very much,
especially taking
into account that you
get those $300 for free.
$300 divided by 0.02 is a lot.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, yeah, don't--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Let's go with a lot.
MARK MANDEL: Let's
go with a lot.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Then what else?
MARK MANDEL: Vision API.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh
yeah, the Vision API.
Vision API, it is really cool.
It's one of my favorite
APIs, because it
allows you to do things that
basically seem like magic.
MARK MANDEL: It's magic, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it's basically magic.
And everything you need to
know is how to use JSON.
So it's pretty amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
and it's really cool.
So it doesn't necessarily
work per image.
It works per feature.
So you're asking an image,
say, can we label detection
or OCR this text.
So you could do multiple
features per image.
But the first 1,000 units per
month is free per feature.
So you can get a decent
amount of stuff done there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, I could say
that it is not a huge amount.
So if you have an application
that is actually used,
you will hit that
limit quite quick.
But this is perfect
for development.
If you're doing development and
testing, this is totally fine,
and you will probably
not hit it anytime soon.
So that is really cool.
Then we have a bunch
of other things
that they're not really free.
MARK MANDEL: But
they're cheap enough.
Like, they round down
to zero, I feel like.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: One of
the examples is Pub/Sub.
Pub/Sub is 200
million operations.
It is $0.40.
So basically, one billion
operations is about one coffee.
MARK MANDEL: I like that.
We should do more
stuff per coffee.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
actually really depends.
If you're drinking
coffee in San Francisco,
it is like half a coffee.
So yeah, there's
a bunch of them.
They're really,
really affordable.
So we'll have a
link-- we'll have,
actually, a table with a
bunch of different free tiers
and links to all the
pricing pages and everything
from the show notes.
So if you're interested
in this, go check it out.
But the most important
thing to take into account
is basically, if you want to
get started, use the free trial.
And you can always get the
App Engine plus Datastore,
which scale
automatically, for free up
to a decent amount of traffic.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, I think that brings us to
the end of yet another episode.
Are you heading off anywhere,
Just for Func episodes?
What are you up to?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm going to
edit a Just for Func episode.
And it should come up soon.
Also, I'm working
on open sourcing
the little tool
that I wrote to push
podcast episodes to YouTube.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
going to be fun, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What about you?
MARK MANDEL: When
this comes out,
I will literally be at PAX Dev.
I'm going to be attending.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
PAX Dev in Seattle?
MARK MANDEL: Seattle,
yeah, so that'll be good.
And then in September,
I will be at one
of my favorite conferences.
I will be at Strange Loop doing
a couple little things there.
We'll see what happens.
I need to coordinate
with some people.
But I love that conference.
It's loads of fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds fun.
Maybe next year
I'll attend, maybe.
MARK MANDEL: Maybe, we'll see.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Who knows?
Well, thank you so much,
again, for taking the time
to record a new episode with me.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you very much.
And thank you very much
to all our listeners
for tuning in once again.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep,
talk to you all next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]